hello welcome I have a I have written
this for you so I'm not going to look at
you why I read it but I'm gonna try to
pee but
um it blows my mind Blake Shelton it
blows my mind to be here today standing
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
celebrating my husband by the way Blake
Shelton
you are so deserving of this honor and
the boys and I and
um all of your family your friends your
colleagues could not be more proud
okay let me try to paint the picture of
the little boy Blake Shelton who had a
simple kind of life and a big dream
growing up in a tiny tiny tiny tiny town
in Oklahoma
the backdrop of his life was nature he
was in the woods all day long not
wanting to come home until it was dark
knowing every name of every tree every
species of animal with a soul connection
to country music and what country music
represents
right there
there is no one more authentic than this
guy he lives and he breathes country
music he is a country music jukebox and
it is his DNA he was born to do this and
hasn't done anything because he wanted
to be a star he has just always been a
star
from barely graduating from high school
to Roofing houses and then moving to
Nashville by himself at 17 years old to
chase the only thing he ever wanted to
do in his life be a country singer
with 28 28 number one singles 23 seasons
on The Voice Blake has always stayed
true to himself there is nobody like him
he is a one of a kind guy and the
audiences all fall in love with him he's
humble he's genuine and trust me
wherever we go everybody feels like they
know Blake Shelton
Blick you are a rare human being and for
all the success that you have had in
your life as a singer a songwriter a
musician a performer an Entertainer an
actor a comedian
yeah an entrepreneur
he's the same guy today as he was back
then a country guy with a love for
country music he's magnetic the most
generous person you'll ever know
and always just him no matter where he
goes making people happy laugh making
jokes and always playing jokes
like the reason the reason Blake Shelton
is here today on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame is because you are part of the
country dream
the Hollywood dream and you are part of
the American dream and everybody knows
you are my dream come true
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]